you know with three kids and with busy
lives it's so much about like trying to
survive Mission slips and sneakers but
for Mariska Hargitay and husband Peter
Herman they'll always make time for a
cause that's near and dear so much fun
on Monday Marishka and Peter made a rare
appearance with their three kids August
Amaya and Andrew to celebrate their
induction into the stuttering
Association for the Young's Hall of Fame
honoring the couple's work with the
non-profit organization we're a team in
their loving and kind and you know we
treat each other with love of course the
two have a special relationship with say
their son August is a person who
stutters and his parents are so proud to
shine a light on the 17 year old's
Community there are so many important
voices out there
um who because there's so much
misunderstanding in the world about
stuttering and stutters are received in
a way that's very very difficult so
those voice says stay silent and they're
really
important voices at the event the Law
and Order SVU star said we work hard to
help people whose voices have been
silenced and Peter noted the importance
of allowing people who stutter to speak
and quote that chance to Simply Be
Marishka added that overall it's been a
beautiful Journey we're so honored to be
a part of it truly yeah yeah yeah really
um You Are Not Alone some of the most
important words anyone will ever hear in
their life
as fans know Marishka and Peter prefer
to keep their kids off the gram making
the night all the more special but
recently they've shared some family
moments from the happiest place on Earth
okay people we're leaving
back in December Marishka even made this
declaration after a spin on the
Guardians of the Galaxy ride with her
little ones this is the greatest ride on
Earth and I just want to let everybody
know that
and flashback to 2013 the whole film
stepped out to celebrate marishka's star
on the Walk of Fame and to August and to
Amaya and to Andrew I know that one day
you will grow into an understanding of
how brightly
the three of you shine into me and
daddy's life
and to Peter you're too good to be true
well Ten Years Later their kids continue
to be a source of inspiration and their
romance still too good to be true
whether it's a relationship that exists
you know in the public eye to some
degree or it doesn't I think that you
know our son our son plays basketball
and and his coach says fundamentals
fundamentals fundamentals right and so I
think that when it comes to
relationships and I don't and I don't
even say this as advice because I
because we're not
fundamentals
foreign